こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです
皆様！
おそらく見てる人の95%強が
知ってると思うんですけども！
簡単に言うと物を売ったり！買ったり！
できるサービスのことでございます！
で、まぁ特徴としてはなんか3分で売れるみたいな！
ｳｲｯって出したらもうｳｲｯ、すぐ売れる！
僕もよく
後輩にメルカリで
有用カード買わせてます☆
で、あのもう勿論中古もあるんですけども
新品もあって
定価よりも安く買えるという特徴があります！
で、あの最近なんですけども
まぁ！家に来る人が増え
その分ものも増え！
散らかり！
もう…
壊滅状態なんですよ…
家がもうちょっと物が多すぎて
ホントにどうしようかなっていうことで～
まぁちょっとこれを機に！
はじめしゃちょー
ﾊﾟﾝ
ﾊﾟﾝﾊﾟﾝ
ﾊﾟﾝﾊﾟﾝﾊﾟﾝ
ﾊﾟﾝﾊﾟﾝﾊﾟﾝﾊﾟﾝ
ﾊﾟﾝ…
何売ろっかな
で、メルカリってなんか物の値段を
自分でこう設定できるみたいなんで～
まぁちょっと最初で
よく分かんないんで！
全部1000円にしときましょう！
ついでに
サインも付けときましょう
じゃあとりあえずちょっと出品する物を
ある程度揃えておいたんで～
まずはこちらです！
はい
なんかね、昔たま～に多分使ったと思うんですけど
なんか遊戯王のね、キャラクターがこれを使って
こうやって腕に付けて
こうやってデュエルすると思うんですけど
そんなに目立った汚れ…
は、多少ありぐらいだと思います
出品します！w
続いてこちら！
ルービックキューブです
いやなんかでもこれで結構
やり込んでた記憶があるんですよね
ルービックキューブちょっと覚えようと
思ったんですけどやっぱ難しい！
（苦戦中）
ルービックキューブ僕2，3個持ってるんで
まぁ1個ぐらい出品してもいいのかなと思って
こちらも出品させていただきます！
次がこちらです！
これ見覚えあると思います
なんか昔の動画でね
この子が喋ってた記憶があるんすよね
えいちゃんだ
アバンティーズのえいちゃん…
が、役をやってたやつですw
結構高かった覚えがあるんですよこれ普通に
まぁ、こう出品者から1言コメントするとすると
口が開くんで～
ふw
名前がビダル・サ・スーンらしいので
出品します！
そしてこちらですw
ポプ子ですね
前髪ちょっと短くね⁉
あ、生えた生えた
なんか僕ノリでゲーセンで
なんかぬいぐるみを沢山取っちゃうクセがあって
気付いたらなんか家中がぬいぐるみになってて
年功序列順にいくと
この子が1番下になってしまって
許してw
はい、あとはこちらです！
13.5ユーロで買いました！
ローマの戦士のおもちゃです！
これ確か大学ぅーーう”…生の時に
イタリアに旅行したことがあって
その時に～
これガチなんですけど鎌田さんのお土産を！
買おうと思って～
ローマでこれ買ったんですよ！鎌田さん用に
けどちょっと渡すタイミングが無くて～
持ち越しになってしまい、今家に置いてあります
ポイントとしては交換用のヘルメットと盾が
ついているので
カスタマイズして戦うことが出来ます！
おめでとうございます！
いや多分鎌田さんはこれを貰っても
「…うん」と言いそうな気がしたので
出品させていただきます！
続いてはこちらです！
もう動画で～
活躍したこともあると思います
ドラです！
僕の手違いで今ドラが家に2個あるんですよ！
実は！
普通に、2個はいらないんで
出品させていただきます！
これも1000円です！
ﾊﾞｰｰｰｰｰｰｰｰｰｰﾝ
あと2品あるんですけども
ここからは結構マジで普通に
って、なるぐらいだと思います
お次はこちら！！
ドミネーターです！！
（拍手）
適正ユーザーみたいです
待ってこれマジで高かった気がするな～…
なんかドミネーター僕…
結局2個持ってるんで～
いいと思うんですよね
売っても1個ぐらい
おっ
おぉ
あぁ！
良い人です
おわっ
はっ！
くらえーーーーっ！！
ﾊﾞﾊﾞﾊﾞﾊﾞﾊﾞﾊﾞﾊﾞﾊﾞﾊﾞﾝ！
はい、という感じで
犯罪係数の高い人を裁ける銃でございます！
飾っておくだけでも
めちゃくちゃカッコいいと思うんで
これはマジで
お買い得だと思いますよ☆
さぁ最後の出品です
最後はこちら！！
ババン！
僕が長年使っていた
一眼レフカメラ
EOS 70Dでございます！
ごめんなさい、レンズはないですけど本体です！
電池も抜いてあるんですけども
全然本体は、バリバリ現役です！
何ならこの、ここの液晶フィルムも貼ってあります
ただ、あの
僕80D新しく買ったんで～
70D使うことがなかったんですけど
これで誰かに使ってもらえるんだったら！
僕は全然出品してもいいなと思ったんで
今回出品させていただきます！
はい、という感じでこちらの物を！
全部出品させて
いただきます！
で、
ひょっとしたらいらないって方も
いるかもしれないんですけども！
全部ちょっとサインを！書かさせていただきます！
それじゃ、書かせていただきます！
（サイン中）
あれ、ヤベェ終わった
ちょ、ごめんなさい
ビダル・サ・スーンには書けないので
これは色紙の！サインをつけさせていただきます！
（ルービックキューブ片面揃え中）
（サイン中）
これはサインを維持するなら
多分崩さない方がいいやつかもしれないですね
（引き続きサイン中）
というわけでですね
ちょっとメルカリの出品用に写真を
撮らせていただきます！
ﾌﾞｯw
ﾊﾞﾊﾞﾊﾞﾊﾞﾝ！
ｶｼｬ ｶｼｬ ｶｼｬ ｶｼｬ
はい、というわけでいかがでしょうか！
ちょっとホントにね
買うだけでお得みたいなのもあるんですけど
僕の商品は25日から出品されますので！
皆さん良かったら是非！買ってみてください！
そしてなんとメルカリさんがですね
今日と明日が5周年記念ということで！
ﾊﾟﾝﾊﾟﾝﾊﾟﾝﾊﾟﾝ
皆さん良かったら是非メルカリで！
僕が使ってた物買ってください！
（ﾊﾞｷｭｰｰｰｰｰﾝ！）
そしてなんと僕だけではなくですね
今日から6月の30日まで
色んなクリエイターさんやタレントさんが！
色んな物を出品しているみたいで
ございます☆
いやでも俺が1番破格な自信はあるんですけどね？
というわけで詳しくは概要欄を見てください！
じゃあな！
ﾊﾞﾊﾞﾊﾞﾊﾞﾊﾞﾝ！
【END】